british national aidan aslan had been
fighting with ukraine's 36th marine
brigade for four years already but this
was the last video he sent home a free
man if you're watching this it means
that we've surrendered
we've lasted a month run out of
ammunition
food
the only thing we had left was water
now he and another british national sean
pinner are in the custody either of
russia or of separatist militias and
have appeared in video that we won't
show you on russian state tv
their request that boris johnson used
what influence he has over ukraine's
president to swap them for this
ukrainian businessman and politician
victor medvedchuk is an interesting man
he's a close ally of vladimir putin he's
godfather to his daughter and he is an
extremely wealthy ukrainian businessman
he ran a pro-russian political party but
then he was thrown into jail on treason
charges last year escaped briefly and is
now back in ukrainian custody so whether
he is released will now be a test of how
far vladimir putin is prepared to go for
his ukrainian friend and ally
his wife has been imploring whoever she
can on youtube to secure his release in
exchange for the two british men
addressing vladimir putin the saudi
crown prince and boris johnson too
mr prime minister you have a great
influence on president zielenski if you
are not indifferent to the faith of your
subjects help their family and friends
return idon and sean
help me return victor
sky news met with the two british men in
january before the long siege of
mariupol
pinner insisted then he wasn't just
there for the ride i'm married a
ukrainian i've got every much right to
be here and the guys it's taken me a
long time to integrate here
so the guys know i'm not
you know a war tourist or a war junkie
and i'm with an organised unit i'm with
the government and i'm with a contracted
soldier
[Music]
but russia wants the public back home to
think that ukraine's forces are packed
with foreign mercenaries that their
president will do whatever western
leaders tell him and that ukraine is a
proxy battleground for murky western
interests back home azlin's family can
only sit and hope
they have put him on their tv so
he is now
um
he is alive
but they are now accountable
donna magne sky news moscow